that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk and i'm dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
jonathan is going to be breaking down a
variety of weapon attachments and
talking about how they're portrayed
within our video games expressing your
personality and whim
by customizing your gun i mean i i
generally end up finding a configuration
that i like and sticking with it
if you like this kind of content make
sure to subscribe as we have plenty of
episodes of loadout for you to check out
on our channel including last week's
episode all about the various gaming
tropes of weapon customization and on
top of that we'll still be showing
jonathan new gaming arsenal's every
saturday so make sure to check out those
too right let's get into the chat
so attachments
obviously
getting out your weapon is a very common
thing in video games now
we see
so much seemingly random ones and weird
ones the way they balance is like really
interesting so i want to talk to talk to
you about how they work in the real
world
like
heavy barrels heavy barrels is is a
pretty common one these days what
advantage does a
heavier barrel give you yeah so as with
most of these things that's taken from
the real gun world traditionally a heavy
barrel is
well got one sitting in front of me at
least somewhat heavy it's heavy toward
the rear it's a big thing on machine
guns
so it
heats up less quickly
and is stiffer because there's more
metal in it so although it will it will
wobble less might sound silly but you
know thin barrel will wobble between
shots especially depending on what
forces are being applied by the
mechanism
of the gas system so it's a thicker
barrel wobbles less and it wobbles more
predictably if it's been properly um
stress relieved so a heavy barrel is
desirable for either a machine gun or an
accurate rifle like a sniper rifle some
assault rifles will have a quote-unquote
heavy barrel that is relatively more
heavy so the m16a2 one of the changes
there was a thicker barrel
for the so with the theory of making the
gun more accurate
um of course what it does is make it
more heavy and in that case more front
heavy right
i think this is something very
recognizable in video games today as
well as having
an underslung grenade launcher i think
that's very common
sort of unlocked attachment
but
again from the things that we've
discussed they're not always implemented
well it's it's in a video game it feels
like you're just sort of eyeballing
and guessing it whereas
i don't know if you said it had it on
this example but they usually come with
their own
their grenade launcher scopes
and that's not really something we see
implemented
in video games it's
the weird reticule on the screen
or yeah almost a throwback to early
fps where there'd be literally just a
representation of a site on the screen
yeah rather than the iron sights it's
rare to see grenade iron sights or
optics because nowadays they're more
likely to be i mean that's an early
experimental
version of a grenade site that
piggybacks on the front of the sat site
but yeah it's kind of yeah it's kind of
weird that they haven't
they don't always
do the full job on that almost like the
grenade site is an afterthought i mean
you know you hear stories of certainly
the m79 gunners in vietnam would learn
to aim by instinct and by experience
like an archer so that's again based on
a bit of reality but if you're issuing
this one per squad which or two per
squad in the british army
you don't learn by feel i mean it's a
waste of ammo apart from anything else
you are taught to fire with the site
just like you are the rifle
one thing that i think is very common in
games today like when i play like escape
from tarkov or call of duty i like
having big mags on my weapons just like
keep up the hurt on the enemy or
whatever especially with escape on
target where you've gotta get punched
through someone's armor and they're very
unwieldy but drum magazines aren't
against one of those things that their
life in video games
is much more than their their existence
in real life right there's a lot of
drawbacks to
a drum magazine so why is it that
you know most militaries and and things
like that don't really use
a drum mag yeah well the the kind of one
of the best way to explain this is to go
back in time to the thompson so the 1928
model thompson that was that was adopted
with a drum mag and certainly the
british british forces bought them with
the drums and the 20 round box mags and
before very long they realized that they
were extra heavy extra bulky and it's
quicker and more efficient to just
change out 20 round magazines and
the makers auto ordnance and colt
realized as well that better to have an
extendo
box mag 30 round and just bin the drum
magazine and then you could also
eliminate the machining cuts on the
receiver that would hold up production
although since then drum mags have kept
coming back as an idea they never really
catch on for anything other than turning
live to empty on a range and of course
in the movies and in games
they're a big big thing there
reliability is another issue with them
because you've just got more working
parts to worry about it sounds like some
of the problems that they had back
during their inception have never really
gone away then no i mean even this is an
experimental sa-80 with a american m203
launch on it we should say
there was even a
cmag so 100 round double drum mag
trialled on the sa-80 if you can imagine
that so actually the the one in call of
duty with the drum on it has a hint of
realism about it but
quickly decided it wasn't going to work
and then obviously a very common one
are sort of modern red dot sights
and i think we've we've talked a little
bit about how that's sort of become
it was influenced
all the way back around and now we're
getting mp40s with aircraft sites on i
think any like big firearms fan that
plays video games shares the
frustrations and that but i think this
is what
i suppose a lot of call of duty players
know picatinny rails are also
very iconic um but there's like
obviously different types of
attachment options and rail systems and
stuff
yep this this one has both picatinny or
m1913
mil standard sorry 1913. now a nato
standard by the way it's that ubiquitous
but also um
m-lok slots these aren't just cooling
holes these are for fitting attachments
directly on to those slots so it's
becoming quite common to have an optical
rail on the top and then all of the
other slots will be something like m
lock and i suppose it is
sort of realistic in a way because
um from what we've said before most
firearms that are issued
to armed forces do come with some sort
of of optic now um oh yeah yeah and i
suppose the other things that we don't
really have here are things like
foregrips
um things like we do have that torch on
the bottom yep here
so again this would be something i think
is very recognizable to someone that
likes to customize their weapons in
video games
it does
feel like they it adds a bit of a good
bit of heft once you start
because then these aren't simple devices
are they no like they're glass and metal
for the most part
they do add a fair bit of heft which i
suppose is something that
not a lot of games really plays on like
not really the added
continued continually added weight of a
weapon i escaped from tarkov does it
some some degree with the ergonomics but
it um it is surprising when
you sort of handle it how you know it
feels you can feel
that it's heavier here
and heavier towards you know the front
so i suppose we've got a long way to go
when it comes to the realism of
attachments but i think
the we've talked about before the the
gameplay that it affords
people is
quite fascinating but i know you're
someone that likes to keep their weapons
fairly vanilla i do yeah i'm i'd be
veering more toward that mcx though just
with the simple close quarters optic on
it
um i mean this this
this is a good example actually i mean
this is clearly an immediate descendant
of m16 m16a1 super light at six pounds
in old money you could fire it one even
i could fire it one-handed you know it's
incredibly brilliantly light and then
what do we do we give it a fat heavy
barrel
we add we had additional bits of
mechanism to it we had steel and glass
that had another couple of pounds a
suppressor a flashlight and before you
know it you put back on that weight that
you managed to get off and it's so it's
almost like a dieting thing you know you
are going up and down through history
trying to keep the gun down to that
sweet spot of about seven pounds
there's a lot i mean you could talk
about attachments for ages but it is
fascinating with how much
sort of you you you can throw on a
weapon but it's it seems that
from what i've played and what i'm what
i've learned talking to you we've still
got some way
in in incorporating them in any sort of
accuracy there i think there are still
frustrations when i look at a menu and a
weapons customization and it's telling
me one thing it's like that's not how it
how it works
but in the case of uh video games i
think it's if that doesn't happen then
everyone's gonna be using the same thing
and it's gonna be overpowered right
yeah
yeah that's what it boils down to
and of course you know expressing your
your personality and whim by customizing
your your gun i mean i i generally end
up finding a configuration that i like
and sticking with it yeah um
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
please do like the video and subscribe
and maybe even let me know in the
comments down below or on twitter at a
regular dave what you'd like to see an
episode on if you're more video game
firearms content you can watch our back
catalogue of previous episodes or check
out our weekly series of firearms expert
reacts where i show our friends the
royal armouries a slew of guns to break
down this will be our last new episode
of loadout for a little while so on
behalf of the whole crew i'd just like
to thank you for watching and supporting
the show it's been an absolute joy to
make it and bring it to you guys and
we'll hopefully be back with more
episodes later in the year until then
i've been your host dave dewitt thanks
again for watching and i'll see you next
time
[Music]